I'm Charlene Chu and I'd like you to
imagine you're the mayor of Boston so
let's say you want to reduce energy
consumption in this city that's a good
goal to have so you're thinking about
passing different policies like reducing
the number of private vehicles in the
city center now thanks to this
simulation platform that my lab built
you can actually take your policy ideas
and simulate them in a virtual City of
Boston now
even though you have this you have two
more problems first is Boston could
change in 50 years the population could
go down if your price can go up with all
these uncertainty factors you actually
have way too many possible future
scenarios that Boston could enter and we
just can't simulate all of them it's too
slow so I come in and I developed a
technique to help you figure out which
scenarios you want to test so my
technique minimizes the number of
scenarios you need while also making
sure that you have enough scenario is to
represent the whole possibility space so
once you have these scenarios you can
take your policies your scenarios and
stuff them into the simulation and then
you get numbers out energy consumption
and so you can actually take these
numbers and see which policies fail in
which scenarios and succeeded in other
scenarios but you'd like to know why
they failed and why they could see why
they succeeded and so my second part of
the project is helping you figure out
what your scenarios look like when a
policy fails in doing so you can
actually zoom in and say okay as long as
Boston avoids these scenarios I'm good
to go
or you can say let's actually dig into
why everything fails when population and
ride-sharing go down let's investigate
that you have that option now and so at
the end of the day my research gave you
a tool to figure out what to put into
the simulation and a tool to figure out
what to do with the numbers that come
out of the simulation and hopefully that
gives you the mayor a way to create
better informed decisions on which
policies you should pass